monka w easy easy easy easy easy easy easy so da bin ich ihr seid aber schon ganz schön viele
community ja alle schon am start genauso stelle ich mir den chat vor ich meine ich bin auch nicht
besser auf der treppe was ist einfach was ist eine du meinst du einen stepper lehrer
und einschrift für den sub-blog kekwe business sorry sorry nicht kekwe business kekweight
business natürlich war für den sub extrem easy alles soll ich euch auch mal erzählen was mega
easy ist also richtig nice irgendwie ging das voll an der gesamten progress welt vorbei habe
ich den eindruck weil ich habe kaum einen drüber reden hören das müssen wir ausprobieren und zwar
quasi eine rolltreppe so was in der richtung ja mal gucken also leute ich kann jetzt schon
gleich sagen falls ihr stellenanzeigen habt entweder die besonders lustig sind oder irgendwas
bisschen ernster angucken soll wo ihr euch vielleicht bewerben wollen oder aber was wir
auch schon öfters was heißt öfters was wir eigentlich mindestens einmal pro stream in
letzter zeit gehabt haben falls ihr selbst in stellenanzeige am start habt und wissen wollt
was da ein potenzieller kandidat den man ansprechen möchte so denkt geht schon geht schon
los ja dann schickt her ich zeige euch jetzt war es was irgendwie an der gesamten progress
welt so vorbei ging und zwar habt ihr das mitbekommen was ist das youtube kündigt über vpn
abgeschlossene premium abos wie jetzt glauben die mir nicht dass ich in der bin wollen die das
wissen races zum alter dass die können das überhaupt nicht wissen dass ich nicht in der bin
dass ich nicht in der bin
alternativ bin ich türke oder brasilianer das ist auch billig oder argentinier das können die
überhaupt nicht wissen anzeige ist raus oder vielleicht bin ich gana gana lese oder wie das
heißt das ist ja scheiße youtube live das kostet 16 euro oder bin ich bin ich blöd kostet nicht
16 euro mittlerweile sogar aus auf 16 euro mittlerweile als in 8
ich weiß warum das 16 ich glaube ich hab mal bei der ich glaube ich habe über die
apple also über die youtube app auf ios geguckt was es kostet da kostet es ja
mehr weil apple auch noch etwas abgreift das ist alles ein drecks laden 13 euro
pro monat dafür kann man youtube und light für sechs euro die
ausschließlich werbung aus dem video sind also ich fand die kombination aus
youtube premium plus youtube musik für 1 euro 50 oder so aus indien echt nicht
schlecht razor danke für den zap ja du kannst
youtube nicht mal gucken ohne adblocker beziehungsweise ohne premium und mit ad
blocker wird zunehmend schwieriger ganzen dreck seige alle als waren die
nicht schon genug kohle stimmt ja das ist eigentlich extrem ließ 6 hat wie
viel kostet in der ukraine ich meine sind so viele leute geflüchtet
und
die könnten sich ja per vpn in die heimat verbinden um youtube premium zu
kaufen außerdem die ähnlich viel geld da bin ich aber heute ab heute ukraine ist
es gefühlt halb twitter ukraine wenn ihr die anguckt wie viele leute die
flaggen drin haben also insofern war dann sind wir fit da bin ich ukrainer
für youtube premium das mir auch egal welchen frankfurter streamer welcher
frankfurter streamer streamt dann noch herder steine wie heißt er hält der
stein
nicht herr darsteller alter steine streamt er auch da dachte ich mir dachte
ich mir den habe ich so gerne bei random am südbahnhof gesehen übrigens danke
für den zap razor habe ich schon gesagt aber
bachtin ex kam nicht oft genug sei also einmal wo ich den song nach höhe haben
dann ist gut da mache noch mal playlist hat die gesprächsNE Rock
their Influencer zum südbahnhof gehen wollte heimfahren habe nicht geschwätzt on
dem für den dessa ne bin zum südbahnhof verloren wollt heimfahren und nicht
geschwätzt unter influenza wir hatten bisher noch keinerlei berührungspunkte
wir stammen aus gänzlich unterschiedlichen youtube eras was geht
mir meiner maus ab chat wer von euch ist das zeit ist seid ihr drin ja gibt's zu
jetzt zu einer wasser musste die maus einfach mal kurz ausschalten wieder
einschalten da ging's okay ich mache das noch so jetzt kann ich endlich was ich
seit irgendwie 55 minuten erzählen will endlich erzählen was ich erzählen will
also es geht was wird der maus das ist doch irgendwas mit obs was sie rum
spackt oder da ist doch irgendwas ist doch mit obs ich habe die gerade einen
ausgeschaltet aber irgendwas ist doch mit obs ist was unterm sensor und mein
sensor einpusten
wenn es einfach mal rausziehen und wieder
reinstecken jachi bass wenn ich jetzt wüsste wo ich
das hin habe ich habe das ja an so einem maus pad dran okay ich habe zwei aus
bei draus gezogen und jetzt mal rein ok ach jetzt leuchtet es auch das hat
übelst rum gespackt die ganze zeit das glaubt der empfänger war einfach gerade
problem so aber jetzt kann ich endlich erzählen was ich erzählen wollte und zwar
ich weiß was es ist okay jetzt wieder gut ich weiß was ich weiß was es ist das ist
jetzt nicht jetzt nicht verraten das ist meine das ist meine homeoffice natürlich
meine homeoffice anwesenheit fake software das ist eine zweite maus
eine zweite maus die ich am zweiten rechner habe und das ist keine maus die
man auf dieses automatisch auflade maus pad stellen kann und anscheinend guckt
wenn man diese maus diese zweite maus sie nicht dafür gedacht ist auf das maus
auflade maus pad stellt was ich aus irgendwelchen gründen noch nie gemerkt
habe bisher dann schickt die zweite maus übelste random inputs an die erste maus
also die die die zweite maus bringt quasi die erste maus durcheinander wenn der zweite maus auf diesem automatischen
auf aufladen maus pad steht aber gut zu wissen so kann ich das so könnte ich das ganze auch als
homeoffice anwesenheitsfaker benutzen wie gesagt ich habe ich habe rausgekriegt was ist ein bisschen
anderes oder sowas an ok also jetzt aber meine güte was die ganze zeit schon sagen wollte ja
das habe ich auch gelesen das habe ich auch gelesen was ich was ich übrigens mega dumm finde
auch also aus sicht des arbeitgebers weil wenn der typ was getaugt hat oder wenn die was getaugt haben
auf der arbeit und wenn die ihre arbeit gemacht haben dann ist mir doch scheiß egal ob die den
bildschirmschoner mit einer maus jiggler wiggler wackler irgendwie austricksen oder nicht wen juckt
die sind selbst schuld ganz ehrlich die sind einfach nur dumm wenn die gute leute wegen das
macht überhaupt keinen sinn selbst schuld
so aber genau was ich erzählen wollte was irgendwie gefühlt an der halben progress und
it welt vorbei gegangen ist wusstet ihr dass jetzt esp 32 c6 mit swift programmiert werden
kann apple hat swift native oder irgendwie sowas vorgestellt oder irgendwie wie das wie das hieß
swift embedded oder irgendwie sowas und man kann jetzt esp 32 mit
swift programmieren hier das nicht schon relativ lange wie apple hat das vor zwei tagen vorgestellt
mit swift und ich habe ein beispiel gesehen oder mist das sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus es geht
aktuell nur mit dem esp 32 c6 weil das der einzige ist der von neueren der auf nicht arm auf einer
risk v5 risk v5 plattform oder so basiert ja ich weiß nicht ob ich das schon mal gemacht habe und
ich weiß nicht ob ich das schon mal gemacht habe aber ich weiß nicht ob ich das schon mal gemacht habe
und das ist ja so jeder rest bei pico funktioniert auch in spz und ich habe mir mal das beispiel
angeguckt das ist gar nicht schlecht es also erstes gute ist das verwendet ein ganz normales
spdf projekt ohne irgendwelchen apple schritt und man braucht auch kein mac als das erste schon mal
sehr sinnvoll das zweite ist syntaktisch und so bin ich fand ich bisher auch schon
immer zwölf ganz okay da gibt conflicts also auf jeden fall ist mir das tausend mal lieber als
c++ aber er muss ich halt ein bisschen umgewöhnen aber das richtig coole ist also ihr seht dass die
behalten auch so ungefähr die stadt die standard struktur wie kann man das jetzt nochmal pin ich
fertig geht hat jedes mal ist das irgendwie anders sagt und was aber richtig cool ist dass und das find
ich das finde ich nice dass das so selbstverständlich funktioniert dass die
ordentlichen interop haben ohne beine ausreißen inline zwischen swift und den
c und c++ funktionen von esp edf beziehungsweise wahrscheinlich dann auch
von ok zwischen c++ weiß ich nicht aber zumindest zwischen den c funktionen ohne
dass du irgendwas spezielles machen muss cook das hier sind ganz normale sachen
die fans aus der aus der standard library ja und du kannst auch delay und
so zeug aufrufen also kannst direkt tatsächlich ohne irgendwelche
verrenkungen interop zwischen swift und der sp standard library machen das ist
das wo das ist ja ein bisschen das problem was die rast implementierung für
den sp 32 hat
die
müssen ja alles neu bauen und das finde ich richtig cool
ich bin ich habe schon mal aufgeschrieben dass wir uns das mal
angucken in nächster zeit wobei ich mir da wobei ich mir sicher bin ob wir das
wirklich machen man könnte jetzt ja böse zungen könnten jetzt ja behaupten ich
mache nie was was in der to do liste drinsteht aber das bin ich nicht sicher
ich bin unschlüssig wie sehr das ganze einschlägt und tatsächlich auch wie
sinnvoll und und usable das ganze jetzt schon ist zumal es nur einen micro
controller
typ unterstützt von denen die ich benutzen möchte was auch eben bisschen
verschwendete mühe ist aber nice genau aber nice also ich da muss man echt
sagen ich hätte tatsächlich bei apple nicht mit sowas gerechnet ich weiß auch
nicht was der ja der anreiz da jetzt ist bei apple man die machen ja nix wenn sie
sich da nicht irgendwie versprechen geld zu vielleicht mehr homekit user oder so
ja die machen ja nix wenn sie sich da nicht irgendwie versprechen geld zu vielleicht mehr homekit user oder so vielleicht mehr homekit user oder so
unter
veranda
ja deswegen ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher was sie sich davor versprechen vielleicht steht da irgendwas
bereise oder so was sie sich davon versprechen ja die sind die genau das habe ich mir auch
gedacht die sind irgendwie beim meta mit dabei ich vermute dass die eben endlich
Endeffekt, irgendwie damit sich versprechen, ihre Homekit-Geschichte boosten zu können.
Anders kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Ja, Carplay, also Carplay habe ich nicht gelesen.
Carplay ist aber zur Zeit super beschränkt.
Ich habe ja auch ein Auto mit Carplay.
Es ist nice für das, was es ist, aber es ist halt nicht viel.
Also es ist cool, da wo es funktioniert, ja.
Zum Beispiel Anrufe annehmen, Navigations-App da drauf benutzen oder sowas.
Aber es sind viele Sachen, die sind doof.
Ja, zum Beispiel, dass du Carplay nicht ordentlich ins Fullscreen machen kannst.
Das Elastic Consultant.
Ach ja, okay.
Oh nein, Leute.
Direkter Teams-Call mit dem CEO am Start.
Livestream, CEO-Livestream.
Ja, und wenn ich jetzt länger drüber nachdenke.
Ach ja, und das halt nichts an Autos.
Das Audio-Video-Zeug richtig erlaubt ist.
Also du kannst mit Carplay Playlists abspielen und sowas.
Aber du kannst beispielsweise nicht über Carplay ein Video auf den Fernseh-Stream.
Nein, nein, auf dem Bildschirm im Auto.
Die sagen ja, safety concerns.
Wir wollen nicht, dass die Leute YouTube gucken auf dem Display und dann irgendwie gegen den Baum fahren oder sowas.
Aber die haben ja sonst auch keine Probleme.
Müssen sich halt irgendwie absichern mit einer Warnung.
Ja, ja, genau, sehe ich auch so.
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Es gibt einen Trick, dass es doch geht.
Es gibt wohl die Möglichkeit, zumindest unter Android, quasi so eine gekrackte Carplay-Version einzusetzen.
Das funktioniert wohl.
Da ist da sowas ausgeschaltet.
Es gibt auch so fertige Geräte.
Da ist irgendeine gekrackte Android-Auto-Version mit drauf.
Und es gibt die Möglichkeit, das ist aber unusable.
Zurzeit.
Ich fände es aber cool, wenn das mal einer weiterprogrammiert.
Und zwar, es gibt auf GitHub ein Projekt für Raspberry Pi.
Die haben das Carplay-Protokoll nachgebaut.
Und du kannst jetzt theoretisch von deinem Raspberry Pi Linux-GUI-Anwendung auf das Display streamen.
Das ist aber so buggy und so unfertig und so kaputt, dass es niemand verwenden wird.
Schade, dass es nicht weiterentwickelt wird oder nicht viel weiterentwickelt wird.
Selten sowas schlägt.
Vielleicht ist es öffentlicher Dienst-News.
Was ist das?
Also, mein, seriously, allein schon...
Allein schon die Webseite.
Okay, Leute.
Sagt mir mal bei den Stä...
Wenn ihr was postet, ich hoffe, ich habe nichts übersehen.
Sagt mir mal, wenn ihr was postet dabei, warum ihr das postet.
Also, sprich, wollt ihr euch da bewerben?
Ist das vielleicht was von...
Also, wenn ihr das dabei schreiben wollt.
Ihr könnt natürlich...
Das kann ich auch sagen.
Nein, will ich nicht sagen.
Aber sagt mal nach Möglichkeit, wenn es euch nichts ausmacht, ob ihr euch da bewerben wollt.
Ob das vielleicht eine Stellenanzeige von euch ist oder einfach nur was, was ihr gefunden habt.
Just for fun.
Weil dann würde ich nämlich die Stellenanzeigen, die nicht einfach nur just for fun gepostet werden,
dass wir doch alles durchkriegen.
Also, sprich, die Stellenanzeigen, wo sich einer bewerben will
oder wo jemand selbst eine Stellenanzeige gepostet hat und wissen will, was wir von halten, vorziehen.
Ja.
Wir haben doch schon angefangen gerade.
Quasi jetzt.
Mal gucken, was meine Package-Updates machen.
Alle durch.
Da fängst du deine Ausbildung an.
Okay, na dann.
Komm, Razer, wir fangen damit an.
Simply.
Was war das?
Das da?
Boah, oh, oh.
Sekunde, Leute.
Eine Augen.
Das ist mir zu viel gerade.
Boah.
Schon besser.
Das war grenzwertig gerade.
Schon für mich erst der...
Wie nennt man das?
Red Flag.
Sagen ja die coolen Leute heute dazu.
Wenn die Webseite des Unternehmens keinen automatischen Darkmode-Erkennung hat.
Da weißt du schon Bescheid, was die Webdesigner und die IT-Leute da machen.
Okay, seriously, die kümmern sich wahrscheinlich um wichtigere Sachen.
Aber es ist auch keine wirkliche Red Flag, aber ich find's immer...
Ja, unangenehm.
Ja, ich find auch, man müsste Prioritäten setzen.
Also, wenn die Webseite noch keine ordentliche Darkmode-Erkennung hat
und dann Darkmode auch anbietet,
dann sollte eigentlich alles andere erstmal hinten angestellt werden.
Was interessieren irgendwelche Produktionsausfälle, Server, die kaputt sind oder sonst was?
Darkmode ist das Wichtigste.
Moin.
Nach Möglichkeit...
Mir sind Schnellanzeigen in Deutsch tatsächlich lieber als in Englisch.
Da kenn ich diese 0 nach 15 Formulierungen besser.
Ja, aber die Webseite...
Auf der die Schnellanzeigen am Ende landen, wenn das die Unternehmenswebseite ist.
Die wird ja nicht von HR gemacht.
Und die kann ohne Probleme eine Darkmode-Erkennung haben.
Am besten finde ich ja immer noch die Leute, die Schnellanzeigen irgendwie mit PDFs generieren
und dann zu HTML umwandeln und sowas.
So nach dem Motto...
Personalabteilung schreibt ein Word-Dokument, schickt es irgendwo hin,
daraus wird ein PDF gemacht, das wird dann konvertiert in HTML.
Die Seiten sehen teilweise wild aus.
Okay.
Nice.
Also, zack.
Da fangen wir mal mit der Schnellanzeige vom Razer an.
Was ist das eigentlich?
Simplyhired.de
Wie viele dieser Portale gibt das eigentlich?
Das sieht wieder wie der 20. Stepstone-Verschnitt oder sowas aus.
Tausende, oder?
Gefühlt.
Ich sehe jedes Mal 50 neue.
Wie bekannt ist diese Seite?
Ich habe die noch nie gesehen bis jetzt.
Ja, ne, das reicht ja nicht.
Das reicht ja nicht.
Das reicht ja noch nicht.
Win-Biz-Zack-Full-Stack-Ops-Pull-Stack mit Senior-Win-Biz-Zack-Dev-Ops-Full-Stack.
Das brauchen wir.
Na doch, Security hatte ich doch drinnen.
Zack reicht für Security.
KI.
Ja, das muss heute auch noch rein.
Agile.
Agile Big Data Artificial Intelligence.
Blockchain.
Ach, weniger Big Data auch nicht mehr so.
Mit Cloud-Logs ist eh schon keinem mehr hinter dem Mond hervor.
Also Blockchain, ja, ein bisschen.
Das kann ich euch zumindest aus eigener Erfahrung sagen.
Also gerade die Frankfurter Finanzbranche, die guckt tatsächlich zurzeit nach, also gibt es
einige Stellen, die was mit Richtung Blockchain zu tun haben, weil der Hype jetzt in so weit
abgeflacht ist, dass da auch die ganzen Oldschool-Versicherungen und Banken und alles jetzt mal anfangen,
dass sie das da gehört haben und viele versuchen auch Produkte rauszubringen auf Blockchain-Technologie.
Unter anderem der Laden, wo ich arbeite, ja, womit ich auch Geld verdiene zurzeit.
Das ist nicht, dass ich witzigerweise, ich kenne mich damit jetzt auch nicht so viel besser aus als vorher.
So ein paar Basics weiß ich mittlerweile, aber hält sie in Grenzen.
Muss ich, muss ich aber auch nicht, um das Kubernetes-Zeug dafür zu betreiben.
Meta, was ist denn XR?
Ne, NFT ist wirklich komplett out.
Mit NFT loggst du 2024 keinen mehr hinter, hinter dem Mond hervor.
Ja, Cloud sagt ja heute auch keiner mehr.
Es ist, wenn schon.
Hyper-Scaler.
Extended Reality.
Sag mal, Max, machen die Banken schon was in Richtung digitaler Euro?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Okay, dann lass uns das mal angucken, was der Razer gepostet hat.
Was suchen sie denn hier?
Ein MS Dynamics.
Oh, das klingt, das klingt aber hardcore nach Business Enterprise-Stells oder Microsoft Dynamics.
Das habe ich schon öfters gehört, auch bei mir auf der Arbeit.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt gar keinen Plan, was das eigentlich genau ist.
Was, was ist das überhaupt, wo wir gerade schon dabei sind?
Business Applications.
Enter the era of AI.
Ja, was sonst?
Microsoft schwätzt den ganzen Tag nur von AI.
Oh, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Slim Beats erklärt uns jetzt den Unterschied zwischen Cloud-Anbieter und Hyper-Scaler.
Da bin ich, das interessiert mich jetzt auch.
Ich dachte, dass das eigentlich nur modernes Buzzwords ist für Cloud-Anbieter.
Was ist das?
Cloud, Cloud-Based Suite of Enterprise Resource Planning and Customer, wie sieht denn das aus?
Das sieht schon mal so aus, dass es überhaupt keine Screenshots davon gibt.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie Outlook für Arme.
Hallo, Max, hast du von der Trennung von der...
Leute, es gibt Sachen, von denen bekomme ich mit, von denen will ich gar nichts mitbekommen.
Das musste man heute auf Twitter.
Auf Twitter ja mitbekommen.
Das Ding ist, ich habe, ich weiß weder wer Dante ist, noch wer Laura ist.
Ich habe nur mitbekommen, dass dann die Ex-Freundin von Dante auch noch gepostet hat.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wer das ist.
Das auf die Schnelle habe ich gesehen, das ist irgendein League of Legends Pro oder sowas.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum so was
heutzutage so breit auf Twitter diskutiert wird.
Ich meine, seriously, wen juckt's?
Wen juckt's?
Ich verstehe es nicht.
So, aber kommen wir mal zur Anzeige von Razer zurück.
Ja, Microsoft flippt komplett aus.
Bei jeder Präsentation erzählen die was zu AI.
Letztens hat sich mein...
Ich muss mal überlegen, dass ich jetzt nicht zu viel erzähle.
Letztens hat sich einer bei uns auf der Arbeit aufgeregt darüber,
dass in den Terminen mit Google tatsächlich, also die Google-Leute scheinen
ein bisschen mehr IQ zu haben als die Leute von Microsoft,
dass die Google-Leute
tatsächlich auf Probleme der Finanzbranche eingeht bei Präsentationen und Terminen.
Und Microsoft ist eigentlich überhaupt
nicht interessiert und sie drei Stunden über AI reden.
Und
genau das halte ich mir im Vorfeld, bevor er das erzählt hat, auch so gedacht.
Also nicht, dass Google tatsächlich so gut
drauf eingeht, aber dass Microsoft einfach drauf scheißt, was eigentlich Sache ist,
sondern drei Stunden über AI redet.
Das ist genau das, wie ich mir Microsoft-Präsentation irgendwelche Sachen zurzeit
vorstelle. Ach Moment, ihr habt ein Problem mit Kubernetes-Verfügbarkeit in Azure.
Habe ich euch schon erzählt, dass wir jetzt auch AI haben?
Das ist halt so die Microsoft-Taktik.
Ja, aber Microsoft, uns würde doch mal schon
interessieren, wie ihr denkt, das mit Storage-Anbindung zu machen.
Und wie war das übrigens noch mal mit euren Sicherheitsproblemen in letzter Zeit?
Ja, aber wir haben jetzt AI, Leute.
Guckt mal, hier habt ihr schon neues JetGPT 4.0 gesehen.
Nee, 4.0, wie heißt das Ding?
Light? Ja, ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Ja, das mit Recall habe ich gesehen.
Ist das Recall? Das ist dieses automatische Screenshot.
Ich kann das auch nicht mehr hören.
Und alle, die ich kenne, die
alle, die ich kenne, von denen ich weiß, dass sie Plan haben und in der IT arbeiten,
die können das Thema IT, können das Thema AI auch nicht hören.
Es sei denn, sie müssen auf den Hype-Train irgendwie aufspringen, weil sie Berater
sind oder irgendwie da mitschwimmen müssen.
Aber wenn du die dann fragst, was ihre
ehrliche Meinung ist oder wenn du die privat kennst,
also von allen Leuten, von denen ich persönlich was halte, die sind auch mehr
oder weniger genervt von dem von dem Thema.
Ich glaube, es sind sich alle darüber
einig, dass uns das Thema in nächster Zeit erhalten bleiben wird, dass ich noch
einiges tun wird, aber jeder Satz, den ich jetzt sage, geht mir
persönlich schon auf den Sack, weil ich wieder über das Thema rede.
Deswegen lasse ich es bleiben.
Ja, das mit McDonalds habe ich gelesen.
Okay, also jetzt lass uns mal die Stelleanzeige von Razer gucken.
Da will sich Razer bewerben.
Also lass mal schauen.
Sie suchen einen Microsoft Dynamics Business Central Developer.
Nachdem ich Microsoft Dynamics nicht kenne, kann ich mir absolut nichts darunter
vorstellen. Business, keck, keck, wait, Business.
Warum habe ich das eigentlich?
Warum habe ich keck, wait, Business eigentlich nicht als Emote?
Keck, wait, Business.
Kein keck, wait, Business.
Okay, also Leistung, Betriebe,
Qualifikation, Informatik, DevOps, Visual Studio, Git.
Also männlich, weiß, deutsch natürlich wieder.
Da steht Informatik.
Da steht Wirtschaftsinformatik.
Das ist, glaube ich, eher eine oder Verknüpfung hier und keine und.
Okay, also als Developer verantwortest du
die Weiterentwicklung, Optimierung und Fehlerbehebung von Business Central.
Ach, Business Central heißt dieses Ding von Microsoft.
Ach so, und du bist intern der technische Ansprechpartner für unsere Kunden.
Widerspricht sich das nicht schon in sich,
dass du intern und Ansprechpartner für Kunden bist?
Oder ist das dieses typische
Business-Speak?
Wir sind Abteilung A, Abteilung B ist unser Kunde oder so.
Du entwickelst, optimierst und betreust Softwarelösungen im Rahmen von Kunden.
Wir hatten diese Stellenanzeige eigentlich formatiert.
Du entwickelst und betreust Softwarelösungen im Rahmen von Kundenprojekten speziell für
den Bereich Microsoft Dynamics, NAV, Weiterentwicklung und Wartung von
Erweiterungen des ERP-Systems, Meta- und Neuentführung und Upgrade-Projekt z.B.
Von NAV auf Business Central.
Ok, Punkte ist overrated.
Ich verstehe null, was die eigentlich wollen.
Schnittstellenentwicklung zu Drittanbieter-Software durchführen von Tests,
Fehlerbehebung und Dokumentation und Pflege der ERP.
Siehste, das sind auch schon wieder so Noobs.
Die haben nicht aufgepasst.
Wir praktizieren doch errorless.
Nee, oder wie haben wir es letztens genannt?
Ich hatte doch dafür letztens.
Ich hab, ich hab, warte mal.
Programming.
Ich habe es vergessen, wie ich das letztens gelernt habe.
Einfach ohne Fehler programmieren.
Easy.
Flawless, Flawless Development Design.
Irgendwie sowas.
Nee, Flawless, aber irgendwie Flawless.
Irgendwie sowas hatte ich letztens gelernt, aber ist natürlich nicht ganz gemeint.
So, jeder macht Fehler, wenn er was
programmiert, geht gar nicht anders, außer der Chat.
Was wir uns von dir wünschen.
Abgeschlossenes Studium der Informatik, Wirtschaftsinformatik, Betriebswirtschaft.
Ja, wie jetzt?
Ein BWLer
oder vergleichbare IT-Ausbildungen.
Gerne auch talentierte Quereinsteiger mit Fachbezug.
Mehrjährige Erfahrung.
Also ein paar Punkte würden dieser Stellenanzeige echt gut tun.
Mehrjährige Erfahrung im Bereich Microsoft Dynamics.
Erfahrung im Business.
Customizing Support von Microsoft Business Central sind für dich kein Hindernis.
Sicherer Umgang mit DevOps
und Visual Studio Code sowie Git.
Okay, hier hat irgendjemand der Personalabteilung gesagt, schreibt mal was
zum Thema DevOps, Visual Studio und Git rein, da haben die das einfach reingehauen.
So ein Satz, der an sich überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Sicherer Umgang mit DevOps.
Was soll das genau jetzt bedeuten?
Ich kann im Jenkins
auf Bild klicken oder die meinen Azure DevOps.
Ja, das ist schon wieder was anderes.
Da muss man aber auch dabei schreiben.
Es hat viel Spielraum für Interpretation.
Ja, wenn die Azure DevOps meinen, dann würde es tatsächlich mehr Sinn ergeben.
Ja, das wäre dann so ein bisschen wie wenn einer schreibt GitLab CI oder so was.
Du verfügst du an breit gefächertes im IT-Bereich.
Ach ja, verfügt ihr auch über breit gefächertes im IT-Bereich?
Eingeständige und strukturierte Arbeitsweise mit einem hohen Maß an eigenem Team.
Gut, okay, ich kann zu der Stellenanzeige nicht viel sagen, weil ich keine Ahnung habe.
Razer, bist noch am Start, weil ich keine Ahnung habe, was bei Microsoft Dynamics geht.
Ansonsten ist die Stellenanzeige ein bisschen schlampig geschrieben, muss ich sagen.
Die Formatierung könnte durchaus besser sein.
Und man erfährt insgesamt doch recht wenig.
Das heißt bei weitem nicht, dass das schlecht ist.
Warum sollst du gefeuert werden?
Kannst du oder hast du die geschrieben?
Hast du die geschrieben?
Das heißt bei weitem nicht, dass die schlecht sind.
Aber und das muss ich ja der Disclaimer immer dabei sagen.
So eine Stellenanzeige ist ein bisschen wie das Anschreiben von einer Bewerbung.
Das ist das erste Mal, dass wir mit dem jeweiligen Unternehmen in Kontakt kommen,
wenn man die noch nicht kennen im Vorfeld.
Das heißt, das ist so der erste Eindruck.
Und um den ersten Eindruck geht es ja.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass die richtig gut sind.
Jetzt eine super tolle Stellenanzeige, muss ich sagen.
Ist es jetzt nett?
Was ich gut finde, ist, dass die Homeoffice direkt erst mal offensiv da reinschreiben.
Wie das dann praktisch gelebt wird, steht ja immer noch ein bisschen auf dem anderen Blatt.
Getränke flat, das finde ich gut.
Umfangreiches Onboarding.
Okay, ja, da schreiben viele immer rein.
Wobei ich ja, ich sage das Gefühl jeden Stream.
Ich bin der Meinung, eine ordentliche
Einarbeitung sollte im ureigenen Interesse des jeweiligen Arbeitgebers oder des
jeweiligen Unternehmens liegen, weil ansonsten hast du da jemanden
sitzen, den du bezahlst ab dem ersten Tag, der nichts machen kann.
Ohne Einarbeitung können die Leute nichts machen.
Das heißt, du vernichtest.
Du machst Pepo Burn Money, wenn du die Leute nicht einarbeitest.
Ich weiß, dass Einarbeitung bei vielen halt einfach schlicht und ergreifend nicht läuft.
Dass man den Leuten sagt, ey, setz dich da hin und mach einfach.
Und dann dauert es ein Jahr, bis du mal ungefähr gecheckt hast, was du eigentlich willst.
Aber das ist ja nicht euer Problem.
Das ist das Problem des Unternehmens.
Das Problem ist, die betreiben mit quasi dieser Einstellung und dem nicht
einarbeiten neuer Leute betreiben die Pepo Burn Money.
Das hier machen die da.
Wenn du Leute nicht einarbeitest, verbrennst du Geld.
Und die schlimmsten Auswüchse davon sind dann wie bei dem einen, wo es
letztens so eine News drüber gab, der irgendwie seit frag mich nicht fünf
Jahre nicht mal auf die Arbeit gegangen ist, uns niemand gemerkt hat oder jeden
Monat Geld überwiesen bekommen hat, ihn kannte niemand.
Er war irgendwie bei einem Abteilungswechsel
und da ist das so durchgefallen.
Keiner kannte ihn.
Er war einfach nicht da und er war aber nie weg.
Richtiger Macher.
Also ja.
Okay, nice.
Next Dev.
Das sieht schon sehr hipster aus, wenn ich das Bild sehe.
Aber wenigstens, wenigstens der ist schon mal gut drauf.
Der hat nicht noch nicht so viele Daily
Scrubs machen müssen, als sie das Foto Foto geknipst haben.
DevOps Productivity Engineer.
Moin.
Es Nano.
Okay, sie suchen einen.
Der Fox.
Genau einen DevOps Productivity Engineer.
Ich bin jedes Mal überrascht, wenn wir so einen Stream machen.
Wir machen das ja ungefähr einmal im Monat.
Das heißt, wenn euch das gefällt und nämlich gefollowt seid.
Würde mich freuen.
Und und Chat Community.
Was mich jedes Mal wundert, ist, wenn ich,
wenn wir diese Streams machen, ich mir das angucke, wie viele neue kreative Job
Bezeichnung es immer gibt, gefühlt jedes Mal irgendwas Neues,
wo einer ein paar Wörter randomized hat.
Bestuit, Dankeschön für den Sub.
By the way, ich meine nicht Subscriben.
Ich freue mich schon, wenn ihr followt.
Subscriben freue ich mich natürlich auch, ja.
Bisschen Pepo Burn Money an Bezos überweisen.
Freue ich mich natürlich auch.
Aber Follows sind auch nice.
Ja, die C++ Streams, die ich letztens gemacht habe.
Zu meiner.
Ja, wie soll ich das nennen?
Zu meiner Überraschung, aber gleichzeitig auch zu zum leichten
Pains Champ habe ich festgestellt, dass die C++ Streams sehr erfolgreich waren,
was Zuschauer Anzahl anging, neue Follower und alles,
was im Endeffekt eigentlich heißen müsste.
Wir müssen noch regelmäßig öfters
Vorgas Projekte auf dem Microcontroller mit C++ machen.
Das Problem daran ist,
dass C++ so eine abgrundtiefe Schrott Sprache ist, Alter.
Blockchain Stream.
Ich kann euch zeigen, wie man einen Polygon
Polygon Note aufbaut.
Das wird euch aber nicht viel bringen.
Rust Stream haben wir immer mal wieder ab und zu mal gemacht.
Microcontroller und Rust haben wir sogar letztens gemacht.
Du hast doch zu guten Zeiten gestreamt.
Ich habe vor allem lang gestreamt.
Das eine Mal fünf Stunden plus.
Ich glaube. Wisst ihr was?
Ich glaube, das machen wir am.
Am Montag wieder
oder vielleicht an einem Wochenende Tag, je nachdem, wie viel Zeit es Montag.
Weil Montag habe ich
wieder den ganzen Tag Zeit.
Ich muss ja nicht arbeiten gehen und.
Ja, da ist ganzen Tag Computer Hocken und Proggers.
Da renne ich morgens mal meine Runde.
Oh Kammel, das haben wir noch nicht gemacht.
Was wir im Stream schon mal gemacht haben, ist.
Kobol.
Also.
Tatsächlich.
Wisst ihr, wenn man sich das mal überlegt, so auch mit der Stream History.
Ich meine, ich mache das jetzt ja schon eine Weile.
Und wir haben ja auch das Archiv, wo man das alles sieht.
Wir haben echt alles schon irgendwie mal gemacht, oder?
Alles von Microcontroller.
Bis Web Assembly im Browser bis Linux Geschichten, Kubernetes, Cloud, VMs.
Alles. Wir haben irgendwie jedes Thema.
Irgendwie schon mal ein bisschen gestreift.
Kenne ich nicht.
Ich kann es jetzt auch gar nicht zuordnen.
Ist es ein Streamer, eine Streamerin?
Ist das eine Library?
Ist das ein Microcontroller?
Ja, da müssen wir noch ein gutes Werbevideo machen.
Was macht eigentlich Carlos Matos von New York City aktuell so?
Vielleicht können wir den ja dafür gewinnen.
Wassup, wassup, wassup?
Big Connect.
Das stimmt. Ja, richtig.
Ich habe ja auch gesagt, nicht, dass ich alles schon gemacht habe, sondern dass wir
jeden Bereich schon mal gestreift haben.
Okay, das haben wir tatsächlich nur sehr am Rande mal gestreift.
Wir haben ein paar mal .NET Anwendungen decompiled.
Da kann ich euch ehrlich sagen, da kann ich euch auch nicht allzu viel zeigen.
Da müssen wir uns mal den Florian an den Start holen oder so.
Ich hatte ja schon mal seit einer Weile geplant mit einem unserer Berater von der
Arbeit, der nicht mal bei uns auf der Arbeit ist, der aber mal da war als Berater.
Daher kenne ich den, der witzigerweise auch mein YouTube Zeug kannte.
Wir wollten mal ein Kubernetes Security Stream machen, weil damit verdient er sein
Geld und das war einer der wenigen Berater, muss ich ehrlich sagen, die mir so
bisher unter die Augen gekommen sind, von dem ich mich beraten gefühlt habe.
Ja, das kommt selten vor.
Die meisten Berater haben das Wort Beratung
und mit Beratung nichts zu tun.
Ja, also Consulten ist ja im Prinzip das englische Wort für Berater.
Jemand, den du fragst, wenn du selbst nicht besser weißt.
Und ganz ehrlich, die meisten Consulten und Berater, die ich bisher bisher gesehen
habe, außer mal eine Handvoll vielleicht, die hättest du eigentlich auch nicht zum
Beraten gebraucht. Ja, DirectX haben wir auch mal ein bisschen rumgebastelt, haben
einen Videoplayer gemacht. Ich weiß ja, haben wir auch gemacht.
Also ich hatte in letzter Zeit tatsächlich
nur zwei Berater, von denen ich einen ganz guten Eindruck hatte.
Nämlich der eine, der sich mit Kubernetes Security auseinandersetzt.
Der hatte wirklich sehr viel Ahnung.
Von dem konnte ich mich auch beraten lassen, was ja nicht oft vorkommt.
Und der andere war eher so Richtung BWL
Kram und hat sich mit um unsere Blockchain Sachen gekümmert.
Und ansonsten fällt mir jetzt keiner ein.
So. Also ja, dann lasst uns mal angucken.
Was wollen die denn? DEFG.
Mal kurz die Musik ein Stückchen leiser.
Okay. Also.
Was wollen die hier denn haben? DEFG.
Also Leute, wenn ihr noch Stellenanzeigen habt,
schickt her und sagt dabei, wenn ihr es leaken wollt, ob ihr euch da bewerben
wollt, ob das vielleicht eine von euch ist oder einfach nur just for fun gefunden.
So, also.
Wir haben schon 21 Uhr.
Ich glaube, wir müssen morgen noch mal Stellenanzeigen streamen machen.
Das reicht doch nicht für alles.
Also der DevOps Productivity Engineer.
Hast du Lust, die Entwicklungsinfrastruktur in Abläufe in den DEFG zu optimieren?
Wer ist denn die DEFG überhaupt?
Wobei das erzählen.
Sicherlich gleich, oder?
Ich weiß nicht. DEFG
DEFG.
Was ist das?
Ach so, ich bin bei Jobs immer noch.
Ihr Auto in besten Händen.
Ach, das ist eine Versicherung.
Konkurrenz quasi.
Nee, wir sind keine Autoversicherung.
Außerdem bin ich hier private.
Okay, alles klar. Autoversicherung.
So, zeig mal her. Hast du Lust, die Entwicklungsinfrastruktur in Abläufe in
den DEFG zu optimieren?
Dann hilf mit den Arbeitsalltag vieler
Kolleginnen und Kollegen modern und effizient zu gestalten.
Das Spektrum reicht von Betrieb für sich und virtuelle.
Alter, was ist?
Was ist mit euch los?
Lese ich das hier richtig?
Linux desktops.
Was ist denn mit denen los?
Das ist ja.
Oh mein Gott.
Ob es das?
Ich habe mich verklickt, Leute.
Ich wollte eigentlich das klicken.
Das ist ja nice.
Extremely nice Linux desktops für Entwicklerinnen und Entwickler über
erstellen von Guides bis hin zum Evaluieren und Bereitstellung von Tool.
Die meinen im Prinzip sowas wie wie Cloud9 oder so wie das früher hieß oder
diese dieses Visual Studio im Browser oder was auch immer.
Aber Browser Idees.
Das macht deinen Job spannend.
Okay, das macht deinen Job.
Also ein Pluspunkt schon mal.
Wir hatten die Stellenanzeige gepostet.
Ist derjenige noch da?
Ein Pluspunkt, was ich schon mal echt gut gemacht finde.
Es ist kein.
Übertrieben Selbstlobpreisung über eine Seite, bevor du zur eigentlichen Stellenanzeige kommst.
Das finde ich schon mal gut.
Und es ist echt kurz und knackig.
So mit den Dingern, die interessiert sind.
Das haben tatsächlich Leute erstellt, die sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigt haben
und wahrscheinlich auch dazu beitragen werden, dass die Leute finden.
Das finde ich bis jetzt schon mal ganz gut.
So, also was macht deinen Job spannend?
Mitgestaltung der Standards und der Infrastruktur im DevOps Client Umfeld.
Zusammenarbeit im Team und über Team Grenzen hinweg.
Freiraum für einen FES.
Die finde ich cool.
Die, die, die gefallen mir.
Wir sind diese Nice.
Was du mitbringen solltest.
Okay, dann machen wir Giant Master, dann machen wir die als nächstes.
Welche? Welche ist von dir?
Oh, was weiß ich jetzt nix.
Ach, das da.
Oh mein Auge, Alter.
Machen wir danach.
Also das solltest du mitbringen.
Viel Empathie für die Belange verschiedenster DevOps Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Meine Empathie Bereitschaft skaliert diagonal zu meinem Gehalt.
Umfangreiche Erfahrung mit Linux Distribution im Desktop Umfeld.
Idealerweise auch mit Apple, Mac OS und Windows.
Verhältnisse im OS Package, mein Grundwissen im Bereich Docker, Kubernetes, Helm.
Da würde ich tatsächlich sagen.
Normalerweise würde ich davon ausgehen, dass gerade im DevOps Umfeld das hier Pflicht ist.
Wobei die das irgendwie ein bisschen anders ausliegen.
Ich weiß nicht so genau, was, was man da eigentlich macht.
Ausgeprägtes Interesse an Automatisierung und Infrastructure, Infrastructure, Configure Code.
Hohes Bewusstsein für die Zuverlässigkeit.
Firmware, Wartewagen, IT.
Gutes Verständnis für Compliance Security.
Ja, gute Versicherung, gesunde, gesunden Pragmatismus bei der Umsetzung von Anforderungen.
Okay, darauf darfst du dich freuen.
Es ist in echt dünn.
Okay,
ein sicherer Job, ein attraktives Gehalt 13,5 Gelder.
Ja, das sagt ja noch lange nicht aus darüber, ob das attraktiv ist.
Die können ja auch 13,5 mal nichts bezahlen.
Hast du irgendwelche Ideen, woran das liegt?
Kernel Update wächst alles früher oder später.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Es hängt davon ab, was du benutzt.
Benutzt du Puls Audio, Pipewire, nur ALSA, nix drüber?
Keine Ahnung.
Flexible Arbeitszeitmodell, umfangreiche Homeoffice Optionen.
Das finde ich tatsächlich schon mal ganz gut, dass man das direkt reinschreibt.
Muss aber auch dazu sagen, das sagt nicht unbedingt viel.
Mein ehemaliger Arbeitgeber, der überhaupt keinen großen Bock auf Homeoffice hatte,
der hat auch in die Stellenanzeigen reingeschrieben Homeoffice.
Und wenn die Leute dann gefragt haben, ja, wie sind denn jetzt genau eure Regelungen, hat man ihnen gesagt,
ja, gibt eigentlich gar nichts.
Und dann hat man nie wieder was von denen gehört.
Zahlreiche Trainings und Lernangebote über unsere Kooperationsfamilien.
Okay, das haben viele sowas in der Richtung.
Ach nee, das ist was anderes.
Das ist was anderes.
Habe ich. Ich dachte so 0815 Vorteilsprogramm, was irgendwie gefühlt jeder hat.
Umfangreiche Beratung.
Okay.
Attraktiver Standort, sehr gute Anbindung.
Deutsche Bahn.
Ja.
Die Anbindung alleine reicht nicht bei der Bahn.
Ein Betriebsrestaurant.
Das ist nice.
Kantine ist immer gut.
Bikeleasing, Fahrradticket, Zuschuss.
Darauf darfst du dich freuen.
30 Urlaubstage, betriebliche Fahrradticket.
Ja, finde ich nicht schlecht.
Bewerbt euch bei Tanja.
Also ich finde, ich finde die Anzeige nicht übel.
Kurz und knackig.
Ja, die hundertprozentig perfekte Anzeige gibt es nie.
Mir wurde jetzt.
Mir wurde tatsächlich jetzt.
Ein bisschen wenig klar.
Was sie jetzt eigentlich genau wollen.
Sollte sich um Automatisierung für Linus
des Tops kümmern, aber auch ein bisschen Dogger und Kubernetes.
Hey, aber ich finde es aber trotzdem nicht schlecht.
Ja, 30 Tage sage ich normal, außer man arbeitet weniger.
Ich arbeite nur 80 prozentig, krieg keine 30 Tage.
Hätte aber auch nichts dagegen, würde ich auch nehmen.
Ja, also ich fand ihn nicht übel.
Die Stellenanzeige.
Weiß.
Warum sie jetzt ausgerechnet ein DevOps
Productivity Engineer sein muss, keine Ahnung.
Ab welchem Gehalt würdest du runtergehen auf 80 Prozent?
Kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Ich bin schon auf 80 Prozent runtergegangen.
Da habe ich noch nicht viel verdient.
Das war zu Zeiten, als ich dann richtig mit YouTube angefangen habe.
Und festgestellt hat, man kann auch mit YouTube Geld verdienen.
Beziehungsweise mit Sachen drumherum.
Und da habe ich das reduziert auf vier Tage Woche.
Das war 2011 oder so.
Und damals habe ich noch nicht verdient.
Also keine Ahnung.
Ich würde es immer machen, sofern möglich.
Und natürlich, natürlich sagen wir mal so, sobald du deine Wohnung bezahlen kannst
und nicht obdachlos sein musst und nicht verhungerst, sobald du die Basic Sachen,
die für dich relevant sind, dir leisten kannst, kannst du runtergehen.
Was findest du, muss unbedingt drum stehen.
Also das ist.
Ganz schwierig zu sagen.
Ich meine, da muss man jetzt wissen, was ihr eigentlich genau haben wollt.
Ja, Full Stack Dev für was?
Was soll er machen?
Genauso.
Also ich kann euch so.
Ich kann euch einen allgemeinen Tipp geben.
Es gibt drei Sachen, die man machen kann.
Also das ist jetzt so meine Sache, die ich mir immer denke.
Dabei es gibt drei Sachen, die man als
Unternehmen machen kann, dass Leute zu einem kommen.
Das erste ist.
Man kann die Leute mit Geld zu kacken.
Das funktioniert.
Wie lange die dann da bleiben, sei mal außen vor.
Aber die fangen erst mal an.
Also man kann die Leute mit Geld zu kacken.
Das geht auch.
Man kann sich selbst.
Das, was attraktiv ist.
Und man wirklich zu bieten hat herausstellen.
Ja.
Das heißt, macht euch mal Gedanken, was ihr wirklich zu bieten habt.
Das können.
Und ich meine damit nicht so Dinge wie Obstkorb.
Ja, oder flache Hierarchien oder eine gute Einarbeitung oder sowas.
Das meine ich nicht.
Das, was die Leute wirklich interessiert.
Habt ihr beispielsweise freie Betriebssystem Wahl?
Habt ihr eine Kantine im Haus?
Habt ihr Kinderbetreuung?
Habt ihr einen?
Bekommt ihr ein Smartphone gestellt, was ich auch privat benutzen dürfte?
So Dinger. Ja.
Überlegt euch mal, was ihr habt und schreibt die mit rein.
Ja, das sagen halt alle.
Ob du das rein schreibst, ob du das rein schreibst oder nicht.
Letztendlich.
Das ist, bis du es selbst erlebt hast, ist das heiße Luft.
Und ansonsten.
Wäre es vielleicht nicht schlecht, weil Full Stack kann ja im Prinzip von.
Wir suchen eine halbe IT Abteilung, können uns aber nur einen leisten.
Bist du wirklich spezifisch in Sachen sein, die ihr sucht?
Übertreibt es halt nicht mit.
Du machst die Telefonanlage.
Den First Level Support.
Du betreust unsere Cloud Umgebung.
WLAN vor Ort.
Hilfst den Leuten, wenn ihr Drucker kaputt ist.
Und nebenbei programmierst du noch Sachen,
hilfst der Buchhaltung und machst JavaScript im Frontend.
Also so ein Mist sollte man nicht reinschreiben.
Kürzeren Bewerbungsprozess.
Das kann man vielleicht mal erwähnen.
Aber ich denke tatsächlich reinzuschreiben, was man denn, wenn man denn Vorteile hat.
Gibt ja Unternehmen, da gibt es ja nicht allzu viel.
Schreibt das rein.
Und wenn ihr.
Und wenn ihr den Kram gut bezahlt und geht mal wirklich in euch, ob ihr den gut
bezahlt, weil es schreibt jeder rein über durchschnittliche Vergütung oder so was.
Früher haben sie immer reingeschrieben.
Ein marktübliches Gehalt.
Das ist schon so ein Ding, wo ich mir denke, es schreiben alle rein.
Irgendwas von guter Vergütung.
Vielleicht könnt ihr eine Range reinschreiben oder so was.
Das finde ich auch immer gut.
Höhenverstellbare Schreibtische, moderne Arbeitsplätze.
Das sind durchaus so Dinge.
Kann man da reinschreiben.
Ansonsten seid ehrlich, was ihr sucht.
Wenn ihr jemanden sucht, der das kann.
Also wenn ihr, wenn ihr auch fein mit
Quereinsteigern seid, dann schreibt das rein.
Also ich habe beispielsweise schon
Stellenanzeigen gestehen, Stellenanzeigen gesehen.
Da stand sinngemäß so was drunter wie und auch wenn das hier auf dich jetzt nicht
perfekt zutrifft, freuen wir uns trotzdem über deine Bewerbung und bla bla bla.
Dann müsst ihr natürlich, müsst ihr natürlich wissen, was da bei euch passt.
So was finde ich immer gut.
Okay, dann lasst uns jetzt mal schnell angucken, was bei.
C
O E O IT
abgeht.
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen, wer das gepostet hat.
Aber derjenige möchte sich dort bewerben.
Okay, die haben erst mal CSS gesetzt für Uppercase alles.
Das erste, was mich schon nervt.
Ich persönlich bin ein alles Kleinschreiber.
Ja.
Alles Kleinschreiben habe ich kein Problem mit.
Aber Uppercase ist irgendwie cringe.
Ja, wenn ihr Full Remote sucht und anbietet, würde ich Full Remote auch einschreiben.
Fachinformatiker Systeme ach so, die suchen ein Azubi.
Wir machen IT für den Mittelstand.
Dabei betreuen wir unterschiedliche Unternehmen und Institutionen bei allen
Belangen der IT Landschaften.
Wie bietet so ausgewählten Betriebszeiten 8 bis 17 Uhr
einen exklusiven Support?
Ist das wirklich, wie man eine Stellenanzeige anfangen sollte?
Ich meine, das ist für eine Ausbildungsstelle.
Da ist man in der Regel, würde ich sagen, wäre ich eh nicht so wählerisch.
Im Zweifelsfall bist du nach deiner
Mindestzeit, die du dort abgesessen hast und deine Ausbildung in der Tasche hast, weg.
Ich finde, das ist keine gute Eröffnung für eine Stellenanzeige.
Wen juckt das so im Detail da?
Das kann man bestimmt dann irgendwie mal reinschreiben, wenn die wollen, dass man,
dass man irgendwie Schichtarbeit oder so, dann müssen sie das reinschreiben.
Azubis Schichtarbeiten geht eh nicht so ohne weiteres.
Ja, und außerdem weiß man gar nicht, ob das auch für einen Azubi gilt.
Also das ist sie.
Ich finde keine gute Eröffnung für die Stellenanzeige.
Sie bieten einen exklusiven Support, an den wir durch diese Stellenanzeige.
Moment, die suchen keinen, die suchen keinen Azubi.
Die suchen keinen, die suchen tatsächlich einen Fachinformatiker System Integration.
Das haben wir hier schon mal gesehen, aber äußerst selten.
Die meisten Leute suchen keinen Fachinformatiker System Integration.
Du machst eine Fachinformatiker System Integration Ausbildung.
Aber danach wird irgendwas anderes gesucht.
Ja, im Endeffekt.
Im Endeffekt suchen die einen Support Mitarbeiter
oder einen IT Support Engineer oder
whatever man da schöne, schöne Konstruktionen an Jobs drumherum bauen kann.
Sie suchen im Endeffekt einen Support Mitarbeiter, was First Level heißt wahrscheinlich.
Unter anderem First Every Level machst du da wahrscheinlich.
Du machst All Inclusive Level,
was echt ultra abfuck ist, könnte ich wetten.
Also ich weiß, du willst dich da bewerben und ich will es jetzt nicht schlecht ausreden oder so.
Ich will, ich will dir einfach bloß sagen, du lässt dich da wahrscheinlich auf sehr viel nervige Telefonate ein.
Wenn dir das klar ist, ist okay.
Ja, aber also für mich.
Für mich persönlich wäre so Telefonsupport beziehungsweise First Level das abfuck extrem.
Hätte ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Okay, was bedeutet das für dich?
Du bist der erste Anlaufpunkt für unsere Geschäftskunden.
Für unsere Kunden sind wir der verlängerte Arm oder die ausgelagerte IT Abteilung.
Wir sind Partner auf Augen und wollen diese auch selbst auferlegen.
Ja, bla bla bla bla.
Deine möglichen Aufgaben.
Also ja, also für mich ist.
Support Sache überhaupt gar nix.
Ja.
Ja, wäre ich auch froh, keinen First Level Support mehr machen zu müssen.
Ich musste glücklicherweise nie richtig First Level Support machen.
Du stehst telefonisch per Mail und auch persönlich zu Verfügung.
Persönlich. Okay, let's go.
Auf den E-Roller und hinfahren.
Würdest du First Level Support machen,
wenn das Geld stimmt?
Ich würde.
Ich bin ja käuflich, was das angeht.
Hat Spaß gemacht.
Wenn es dir Bock macht, ist gut, ja.
Ich kann ja immer nur sagen, ob das ich kann ja nur sagen, dass mir kein Bock machen würde.
Also ich bin ja käuflich, was das angeht.
Wenn ich genug Geld kriege, würde ich fast alles machen.
Das Problem ist, genug Geld für First Level Support wird mir wahrscheinlich keiner
bezahlen, weil First Level Support meistens nicht gut bezahlt wird.
Also damit ich First Level Support
mache, müsste es deutlich mehr sein, was ich jetzt kriege.
Weil das, was ich jetzt mache, mache ich viel, viel lieber als First Level Support.
Und wirklich sehr viel lieber als First Level Support.
Das heißt, sie müssten mir mal mindestens
das Doppelte bezahlen, dass ich auch nur dran denken würde, First Level Support zu
machen. Und das bezahlt mir für First Level Support keiner.
Und selbst dann würde ich es mir überlegen, weil mehr Geld ist nice.
Aber sagen wir mal so.
Seriously.
Ab dem man gut auskommt mit der Kohle, ist weitere Kohle cool.
Aber nicht um jeden Preis so.
Okay, du verwaltest deine To Do's in unserem Ticketsystem.
Komm ich über diese, ja gut, Support halt.
Du hast unsere Monitoring Lösung.
Ja, genau.
Du leistest Unterstützung bei der Einführung neuer IT
Telekommunikationssysteme und betreust eigene kleine IT Projekte.
Weil du betreust eigene kleine IT Projekte
neben dem du den ganzen Tag Support machst, wie soll das funktionieren?
Oder geht bei denen alles perfekt?
Die haben wenig Support-Geschichten.
Für wie viel Geld, Geld verzichten würdest du wieder Turnschuhatmen machen?
Ich habe das gern gemacht.
Ich hätte gar keine Probleme damit, wieder
ab und zu mal ins Rechenzentrum gehen zu müssen.
Ich habe das immer richtig gerne gemacht.
Leider sind diese Jobs zunehmend seltener in Unternehmen selbst.
Das ist viel mehr ausgelagert.
Den Standort, Standortbetrieb, Rechenzentrumsbetrieb.
Und dann leider halt auch.
Für jeden Fall bei irgendwelchen Billigjobs.
Ich fand die Kombination geil.
Damals noch
auch noch nach der Ausbildung beim Provider fand ich die Situation geil.
Du hast dich.
Du hast das war wirklich Full Stack.
Okay, war nicht wirklich Full Stack.
Das stimmt nicht.
Anwendungsentwicklung war da nicht dabei.
Aber es war, sagen wir mal so, es war
voller Infrastruktur Stack.
Du hast dich um die Anwendung da drauf gekümmert, um die Überwachung da drauf
gekümmert, um die um die
Bildungsgeschichte da drauf gekümmert, um die Automatisierung, um den Aufbau, um
alles mit der Kiste inklusive Einbau ins Rechenzentrum.
Teilweise patchen neue.
Na.
Ja, ist diese Dinger LC Stecker?
Ja, Glasfaser Dinger.
Dran machen, gucken, wo die rauskommen.
Konsole anschließen alles.
Das fand ich cool.
Das fand ich cool. Das hat mir Spaß gemacht.
Das das würde ich heute auch wieder machen.
Das fand ich nice.
Am besten habe ich euch ja schon ein paar mal erzählt.
Am besten war
durch durchs dunkle Rechenzentrum in Frankfurt, durch drei dunkle Rechenzentren
in Frankfurt morgens früh.
Eine Sache ist.
Die ich.
Also warum ich es nicht machen, wahrscheinlich nicht mehr machen würde,
ist, weil ich dann jeden Tag nach Frankfurt müsste.
Durch die ganze Turnschuhe Admin Geschichte.
Das wäre für mich der Grund, warum ich nicht mehr machen würde.
Dadurch, dass ich nicht mehr jeden Tag mit der Bahn fahren muss.
Und das ist tatsächlich hauptsächlich mein größtes Problem an nach Frankfurt
fahren, ist die Zeit, die drauf geht, mit hin und zurückfahren
und die Unberechenbarkeit der öffentlichen Verkehrsmittel.
Wenn es ein Laden wäre bei mir um die Ecke,
der mir für Turnschuhe Admin Tätigkeiten
ordentlich was bezahlen würde, wäre das was, wo ich auch heute noch machen
würde, ja.
Wer mal versucht hat, ein Playcenter alleine ins Rack einzubauen, da weiß
wie, wie, wie sowas ist.
Ich weiß noch, wo ich im Felix zusammen mal ein Playcenter eingebaut habe und das
dann hing auf halb acht im Rack.
Die Dinger sind ultra schwer.
Ich weiß nicht, was, was so ein Playcenter wiegt.
40 Kilo oder so.
So ein bestücktes oder nicht komplett bestücktes Playcenter.
Wir waren sicherlich nicht so blöd, namens voll bestückt vorher.
Was dann Turnschuhe Admin ja einer, der noch an die Hardware dran muss.
Ja, ich weiß noch, wie ich mit Felix da gestanden habe und dann hing das Ding im
Rack und wir mussten das festhalten, dass es nicht, weil es halt, wenn das so auf
einer Schiene ist und auf der anderen Schiene nicht richtig.
Und wir mussten es auf der anderen Seite festhalten.
Und die Dinger sind lang.
Die sind fast einen Meter, die sind über
einen Meter lang, würde ich sagen, oder einen Meter lang.
40, 50 Kilo über einen Meter lang.
Dann müsst ihr den Arm ins ins Rack reinstecken.
Und da stehen da zwei.
Dicke untrainierte Azubis mit jeweils dem Arm im Rack und versuchen 50 Kilo
Playcenter zu halten auf einer Entfernung von einem Meter.
Weil das also war schon ein paar
heftige Sachen bei damals.
Aber letztendlich erinnere ich mich da heute immer noch gerne dran.
Weiß ich nicht, kann ich nicht sagen, habe ich nie gemacht.
Einfach aufs Cloud engineering kann ich.
Da kann ich tatsächlich aus erster Hand draus berichten.
Network engineer weniger.
Übrigens, dazu kann ich was sagen zum Thema Network engineer.
Vielleicht wäre das ja auch mal was.
Und zwar fällt mir nur gerade ein.
Und zwar
ich habe heute diese Nachricht bekommen.
In Teams auf der Arbeit.
Und das ist unser einer unserer Network Engineers.
Und der hat das geschrieben hat.
Ist mir nur gerade eingefallen bei dem Thema Network engineer.
Ja, also ich kann da persönlich wenig zu sagen.
Habe ich nicht gemacht.
So, also weiter.
Stellenanzeige.
Das hat man uns.
Wir zählen auf deine Mitwirkung bei diversen komplexen IT.
Du dokumentiert die Systeme unserer Kunden.
Fingst am besten auch neue Lösungen mit.
Ja, okay.
Wurdest du geliebt?
Es gibt ein paar Leute, die wissen das auf der Arbeit.
Die kannten mich.
Witzigerweise vorher schon.
Sind doch meistens ein bisschen jüngere.
Die haben damals mein YouTube Zeug geguckt.
Witzig eigentlich, dass das so um um drei Ecken man die Leute kennt.
So was träumt man.
Okay, deine Qualifikation.
Du hast eine Ausbildung im Bereich IT bereits erfolgreich abgeschlossen.
IT Kundenbetreuung ist für dich Daily Business.
Administration von PCs.
Noch machst du doch mit links.
Die Verwaltung von Active Directory Domain Service lässt sich nicht schützen.
Jetzt machst du nebenbei.
Okay, Windows Server aller Jahrgänge beherrschst du im Schlaf.
Die haben jetzt Microsoft 365 liegt dir total.
Da haben sie das Chat GPT generieren lassen.
Du hast bereits an der einen oder anderen
TK Anlage mitgewirkt und Cloud ist für dich.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt mal, jetzt mal langsam.
Jetzt, jetzt übertreibt zwar nicht ja.
Englisch telefonieren und schreiben.
Also Seriously, die suchen ein First Level Support Mitarbeiter.
Die suchen allerdings.
Nicht wirklich ein First Level Support Mitarbeiter.
Die suchen einen Every Support Level Mitarbeiter.
Also du machst im Endeffekt.
Betreuung von kleinen PCs.
Telefon Support AD Verwaltung.
Windows Administration Microsoft 365 Krempel.
Telefon Telefon Anlagen Kram.
Cloud Infrastruktur.
Also das ist das einzige von den Dingern, die hier.
Also das erste und das letzte ist das einzige, was hier steht.
Bei deiner Qualifikation, was ich finde, was rein was wirklich Sinn macht.
Ja, die suchen einen First Level Mitarbeiter fürs Telefon.
Aber sie suchen im Endeffekt einen Every Level Support Mitarbeiter.
Das ist schwer zu sagen.
Das kann durchaus sein, dass das was taugt.
Aber ich wie gesagt.
Das ist das erste Mal, wo man mit dem Laden in Kontakt kommt.
Mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir,
dass das wahrscheinlich und da habe ich einiges von, dass das wahrscheinlich ein
Laden ist mit sehr rauem Klima, wo du dich permanent mit irgendwelchen Kunden rum ärgern
musst und nebenbei noch noch bei allen anderen Systemen die Finger mit dabei haben musst, dass
es irgendwie läuft.
Ich glaube, dass und wahrscheinlich ist es nicht gut bezahlt.
Wie gesagt, keine keine Facts oder so.
Das rate ich jetzt einfach nur.
Also.
Ich persönlich würde Abstand von dem.
Spricht mich nicht an.
Was nichts heißen muss.
Das kann durchaus was taugen.
Aber die Stellenanzeige gibt es aus meiner Sicht nicht her.
Dass es sich für mich so anfühlt, als möchte ich dahin.
Doch diplomatischer kann ich es jetzt nicht mehr sagen.
Zumindest bis jetzt.
Leistung der Anstellung.
Du erhältst einen Firmenwagen, der von dir auch privat genutzt werden kann.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil die dich quer durch Deutschland schicken zu irgendwelchen Sachen hin.
Smartphone, Laptop sonst alles auf die du benötigst.
Die die schicken.
Das machen die nicht aus reiner Nächstenliebe.
Die schicken dich.
Die schicken dich garantiert.
Die schicken dich garantiert quer durch Deutschland, wenn ich sowas lese.
Meine Vermutung.
Das ist kein Inkasso Unternehmen.
Das ist irgend so ein.
Das ist das, was ich früher Frickelbude genannt hätte.
Was ich nicht, was ich gar nicht negativ meine.
Sondern ich habe mir meine Ausbildung danach auch bei so einer Frickelbude gearbeitet.
Und vielleicht kommen meine negativen Erfahrungen einfach daher.
Und ich projiziere das jetzt hier drauf.
Aber mir gefällt es nicht.
Als Unternehmen wollen wir unseren Erfolg mit allen teilen.
So natürlich auch mit den mit den Mitarbeitenden.
Neben regelmäßigen Events über MonkaS gibt es weitere vergünstigende Leistungen,
die dir zugutekommen. Jobrat ist vielleicht auch an dem.
Ja, das hat ja mittlerweile jeder.
Kannst dich oder per Mail an.
Also mein Fall wäre es nicht.
Hat dir das geholfen?
Giant Master 95.
Ich weiß nicht.
Was die Benen, die hatten Benefits.
Keck Wait hatten die Benefits.
Was hatten die für Benefits?
Ich sehe keine.
Was das Jobrat kannst.
Hat jeder. Jeder hat Jobrat.
Und das mit dem Firmenwagen.
Ganz ehrlich, ich vermute, dass es nicht aus reiner Nächstenliebe passiert,
sondern dass sie dich quer durch Deutschland schicken wollen und deswegen Firmenwagen kriegst.
Also spricht mich gar nicht an.
So soll ich irgendwas anderes vorziehen?
Also ich denke mal 1 2 können wir heute noch machen.
Dann machen wir morgen einfach noch mal ein Stream in der Richtung.
Oh mein Auge.
Okay, wir machen.
Wir machen Sven Desk, weil das hat hat er glaube ich schon echt.
Lange vor langer Zeit gepostet.
Welche? Welche ist denn das hier?
Die gucken wir uns. Die gucken wir uns zum Schluss an.
Die ist bestimmt richtig cringe.
Welche hiervon ist das? Ist das Sven Desk?
Den hat man gerade schon.
Ach, hier, Sven Desk.
Ah, okay, also.
Englische Stellenanzeigen sind wir
für heut Abend zu HI gan.
Also guck uns Sven Desk an, ist auch auf englisch.
Was suchen die denn?
Ein Senior-, Fullstack Developer,
Mfx, Focus, Backend, Kotlin.
Uiuiuiuiui.
Das ist ja mal.
Pleading Edge, modern hier.
Ok.
Gehen wir rein in den Cloud.
Okay, sie entwickeln Cloud-Accounting-Software.
Okay, bla bla, Selbstbeweihräucherung.
Strong Culture, Innovative Spirit, Unweavering Passion.
Okay, was ist ihre Mission?
Wir sind hier beim Gitarre-Kundkurs.
Die Probleme von dem Benutzer erzählt bekommt, dann die erstmal...
Ah, kommen die aus Schwaben irgendwo?
Hört sich sehr schwäbisch an, so ein bisschen.
Gibt es hier dann auch auf Deutsch die Anzeige?
Ich kenne einfach die Formulierung besser.
Okay, du bist voller Hingabe, bist du ein Software-Developer.
Dein Fokus liegt auf Backend.
Das sind so super advancede Wörter.
Da weiß ich zwar grob, was die heißen, aber die direkte deutsche Übersetzung kann ich euch gar nicht sagen.
Das heißt so...
Nicht detailliert, das heißt...
Was heißt denn das?
Besonders ordentlich, besonders ordentlich heißt das.
Du designst die Software besonders penibel, ordentlich, sowas in der Richtung, ja?
Sorgfältig trifft es ganz gut, ja?
Besonders ordentlich bist du.
Okay.
Weiterer Fortschritt, was Software-Performance und Benutzerfreundlichkeit angeht.
Jetzt kriegen wir erzählt, wie man hier einen richtig krassen Impact machen kann.
Exciting neue Backend-Features in Kotlin Spring Boot.
Okay, die sind auf jeden Fall schon mal in 2024 angekommen.
Sowohl Spring Boot ist seit ein paar Jahren schon angesagt, was Java-Anwendungen angeht.
Spring Boot ist, ich habe keinen Plan von Java-Entwicklung, Enterprise Business Java-Entwicklung.
Außer, dass ich meine Klassen natürlich Factory Manager, Singleton, Observer,
oder Pattern-mäßig programmiere.
Ne, also ich habe von Enterprise Java, beziehungsweise von Business-Anwendungen Java, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß aber, dass Spring Boot sehr angesagt ist.
Und dass Spring Boot quasi Tomcat ist, nur dass es kein Tomcat mehr ist.
Das ist quasi jetzt der Tomcat im Framework und nicht mehr das Framework im Tomcat ist.
Das hat mir mal ein Java-Entwickler so erklärt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt, Leute.
Ist das richtig?
Das ist das Framework.
Im Endeffekt ist das wie ASP.NET Core.
Das bringt auch einen Web-Server mit.
Du hast quasi eine lauffähige Anwendung, ohne dass du einen Application-Server extra reinladen musst.
Das ist wie ASP.NET Core im Endeffekt.
Oh, Agile Scrum Team.
Maintaining and Develop them.
Ja, okay.
Du bist hier die Speerspitze der Migration von PHP zu Kotlin.
Das finde ich cool.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall definitiv kein Job für mich.
Fehlt mir jegliche Erfahrung von.
Aber das fände ich persönlich einen interessanten Punkt, der mich als Entwickler interessieren würde.
Umstellung von PHP auf Kotlin und dementsprechend Java.
Maximum Performance und dreidimensionales, diagonales Skalieren.
API ist entsprechend der OpenAPI.
API-Specification, Ownership of your Team-Services and help shape our DevOps-Culture.
You share your knowledge with your Team-Contributors.
Okay, das ist ja auch sehr 0815.
React TypeScript and follow a holistic approach.
Also, holistic ist so ganzheitlich.
Ich hätte jetzt ehrlich gesagt vermutet, dass wenn jemand was von holistic approach schreibt,
dass man...
Node im Backend verwendet, OpenAPI gleich REST.
Nee, OpenAPI ist das, was du teilweise bei Swagger immer siehst,
wenn du dir mal so eine API-Doc anguckst.
Da gibt es irgendeinen, ich will es nicht Standard nennen,
da gibt es irgendwie so ein paar Guidelines.
Ich habe mir das nie im Detail durchgelesen, so ein paar Guidelines.
Zum Beispiel, dass du Restendpunkte, die...
Also, dass du deine Restendpunkte...
Zum Listen deiner Entities quasi immer plural nennst und solche Geschichten stehen da drin.
In OpenAPI.
Qualification.
Mehrere Jahre Erfahrung als Fullstack-Developer.
So richtig muss ich ehrlich sagen, habe ich da den Fullstack jetzt noch gar nicht gesehen.
Okay, es ist Frontend und Backend, aber das ist jetzt nicht so außergewöhnlich,
aber ich finde es gut, dass sie es nicht übertreiben, dass sie nicht noch zusätzlich sagen,
ja und dann machst du noch Kubernetes in der Cloud und dann kümmerst du dich auch noch um unsere Pipelines
und dann kümmerst du dich auch noch um unsere Infrastruktur-Tests und dann...
Also, weniger ist mehr in dem Fall.
Okay, mehrjährige Erfahrung, man kennt sich super aus mit Kotlin und Springboot.
Man weiß, wie man objektorientiert programmiert.
In Java... Kotlin haben wir sogar auch mal ganz kurz im Stream gemacht.
Fand ich nice.
Aber nicht nice genug, dass ich mich mehr im Java...
Ökosystem beschäftigt habe seitdem.
MySQL, gut, das wundert mich nicht.
Die kommen von PHP.
Dass sie auf MySQL rumgurken, wundert mich nicht.
Da kann man den gleich mal verkaufen, dass Postgres beste ist, wenn man da ist.
So, man hat ja schon vorherige Erfahrungen mit TypeScript, JavaScript, React oder Angular.
Okay, die schreiben einfach irgendwelche Frontend-Geschichten.
Letztendlich, wenn du denen erzählst, ich habe Erfahrungen...
...mit Vue ist das wahrscheinlich auch gut.
Man kommt da mit rein, ganz ehrlich.
Sogar wenn man Svelte-Erfahrungen hat, gerade mit Svelte 5 wird das auch ein bisschen ähnlicher.
Ich gehe mittlerweile stark davon aus, dass wenn du ein Frontend-Framework ganz gut kannst, kommst du in die anderen auch ganz gut rein.
Okay, Design-Pattern, Security, Software-Development.
Oh, wie enthusiastisch sind wir.
Enthusiastisch sind wir über den DevOps-Approach.
Und wir kennen uns auch aus oder sind, ich kann die Dinge immer ultra schlecht übersetzen, bekannt mit Themen wie REST, Docker, NoSQL, Cloud-Based Infrastructure.
Okay, einfach mal ein bisschen was gedroppt.
Deutsch und Englisch.
Und man programmiert gerne.
Kotling, Springboot, JavaScript, TypeScript, React, REST.
Naja, besser als SOAP.
Docker, SQL, AWS, Terraform.
Ach doch, ein bisschen Infrastruktur.
So, so, habe ich bis jetzt noch nichts von gelesen in der ganzen Stellenanzeige.
Wow, jetzt wolltest du es aber wissen.
Freedom.
Freedom to work from wherever you choose.
Okay, das heißt, nicht nur Homeoffice, sondern du kannst sogar aus irgendeinem Hipster-Café um die Ecke arbeiten.
Define, okay, flexible Arbeitszeit im Endeffekt.
Open-Code-Friday, bring your own carrier.
Da habe ich einmal mitgemacht bei so einem, wie haben sie das genannt, Coding-Camp oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, weiß gar nicht mehr, wie das hieß.
Da habe ich einmal mitgemacht und wir waren die einzigen, wir waren das einzige Team, das einen minimalen Prototyp gebaut hat bei diesem Coding-Bar-Camp.
Und wisst ihr, wer gewonnen hat?
Und das ist auch der Grund, warum ich da nie wieder mitmache bei sowas.
Und am Ende hat das Team gewonnen, die unser Projekt gemacht haben, die quasi exakt die gleiche Idee gerippt haben von uns, aber anstatt ein so könnte es aussehen Prototyp zu bauen, haben die einfach nur eine Präsentation erstellt und die richtig gut geübt.
Okay.
Okay, wird man mal wieder daran erinnert, Business Enterprise, Keck-Weight-Business, so läuft es halt.
Aber dann sollte man das Ding halt vielleicht nicht so nennen.
Wir hätten das auch super präsentieren können.
Ich habe euch ja schon aufgeregt, ich mache sowas eigentlich ganz gern.
Aber wir haben uns halt gedacht, okay, wenn es da wirklich um Anwendung geht, machen wir mal lieber einen Prototyp so minimal, aber nope.
Okay, Ideen einbringen.
Moment, Moment, was?
What?
Das, das checke ich nicht.
Engage in flat and brown back sessions.
Celebrating no...
What?
Hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, Chat.
Damit hat das bestimmt nichts zu tun.
Was ist eine...
Back session?
During their lunch break.
Ach, das ist im Prinzip nicht bezahlte Arbeitszeit.
Okay.
Kann man sich quasi während der Mittagszeit treffen, was futtern und über aktuelle Themen was lernen und so.
Ja.
Ich habe es jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zu negativ dargestellt.
Ganz ehrlich, das ist ja sicherlich keine Pflichtveranstaltung.
Und ich bin jemand, der eh meistens sich irgendwas beim Bäcker holt und sich dann von Rechner hockt oder so, wenn er in Frankfurt ist.
Also, wenn es Arbeitszeit ist, würde ich hingehen.
Ansonsten...
Hocke ich mich lieber an den Rechner und gucke ein bisschen auf Reddit rum.
Okay.
Wenn es dort Essen gibt und es alles bezahlt wird, dann würde ich sogar auch ab und zu mal hingehen.
Ja, je nachdem wie das ist, kann das denke ich aber schon mal ganz gut sein.
Support, äh, Career, Career Journey, Join, äh, ähm...
Frage ist, ob es freie Betriebssystemwahl gibt.
Ja, die, die machen ja auch ein bisschen, bisschen viel Tamtam um eigentlich wenig, oder?
Express yourself in a...
Kannst dich anziehen, wie du willst.
Es gibt ganze 30 Euro für eure Altersvorsorge, nice.
We cover travel costs for your visits to our Offenburg office.
Das finde ich eine gute Sache, ja.
Das ist nice.
Wenn du, wenn du beispielsweise normalerweise von woanders arbeitest, aber du musst da mal in die Firma, dann kriegst du die gesamten Reisekosten bezahlt.
Das finde ich gut.
Jährliche drei Arbeitstage, wo man machen kann, was man will für irgendwelche anderen Projekte.
30 Tage Urlaub.
Urlaub gibt es überall.
Man kann Englisch lernen.
Oh, guck mal.
Man kann auch mal extra Tage machen.
30 Tage extra, wo man dann von woanders arbeitet.
Finde ich, finde ich nicht verkehrt.
Kannst nach Spanien fahren und dort dich für einen Monat in eine Hütte mieten und von da arbeiten.
Ich meine, kannst du ja angeblich eh schon.
Weiß nicht, was da der Unterschied ist.
Okay.
Ich habe mit den ganzen englischen Sprüchen und Formulierungen nicht so viel Erfahrung.
Es macht auf mich aber gar keinen schlechten Eindruck.
Ist das wirklich extra?
Ja.
Urlaub ist keine Vacation.
Ah ja, das oben gilt nur für Deutschland.
Ja, das wird es sein.
Genau.
Du kannst von egal wo arbeiten innerhalb von Deutschland.
Und hier kannst du nochmal 30 Tage, also quasi einen Monat im Jahr arbeiten, wo du willst.
Theoretisch kannst du, also wenn du es richtig machst, kannst du zwei Monate in Spanien sein.
Und wenn du es richtig freifertig machst, wechselst du das sogar ab zwischendurch, dann kannst du dann mal eine Woche weg sein, wenn du irgendwo hinfahren willst.
Eigentlich cool.
Also, ich habe mit englischen Stellenanzeigen nicht so viel Erfahrung.
Ich finde, das macht aber keinen schlechten Eindruck.
Also, wenn man Bock hat auf Kotlin Frontend mit React, also Kotlin Backend Frontend und gerade diese Migrationsgeschichte von PHP auf Kotlin, das spricht mich persönlich jetzt an, weil ich finde es ein interessantes Thema.
Natürlich wäre es für mich ein interessantes Thema.
Ich habe da viel zu wenig Erfahrung in Java-Entwicklung und alles.
Aber das fände ich schon mal ganz cool.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht übel.
Wie groß der Laden ist, kann ich schlecht einschätzen.
Dementsprechend ist es schwer zu sagen, ob das eher Richtung Startup geht.
Also, im Endeffekt, du verdienst so gut wie nichts.
Oder schon ein bisschen was Größeres.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber rein von der Technik her und vom Inhalt her macht das auf mich gar keinen Sinn.
Ich habe da keinen so schlechten Eindruck.
Hast du schon mal Bildungsurlaub genommen?
Nö.
Komm, wir haben eh nur noch 7 Minuten Zeit.
Wir gucken uns doch mal das Video von denen an.
Das ist auf Deutsch.
Wir sind hier beim Gitarre-Grundkurs.
Da müsst ihr sofort raus.
Ich bin Alex.
Ich bin jetzt bei ZEVDESK seit anderthalb Jahren.
Du bist ein bisschen leise, hä?
Bist du immer leiser?
Ich bin im Team Paking.
Ich bin der Dario.
Im Team was?
Im Team Paking.
Ach, Paking.
Ich habe erst Paking verstanden.
Aber da dachte ich mir, warum spricht der Paking so komisch aus?
Ich bin der Dario.
Ich bin 26 Jahre alt.
Ich bin im Team Meerkat seit ungefähr mehr als einem halben Jahr.
Okay, die nennen ihre Teams einfach besonders stylisch.
Also unsere Scrum-Teams haben alle einen PO und einen UI-UXler.
Wir haben pro Team circa vier bis fünf Entwickler, also sprich fast so 50.
Im ganzen Engineering.
Also im Backend haben wir PHP noch für unseren alten Teil und den Rewrite, den neueren Teil, den haben wir jetzt in Kotlin.
Für unser Frontend haben wir aktuell noch AngularJS im Einsatz, aber neue Komponenten, oder wenn Komponenten stark verändert werden, werden dann durch React-Komponenten ausgesetzt.
Was hatten sie noch? Ich habe es jetzt gerade nicht.
Verändert werden, werden dann durch React neue Komponenten, AngularJS im Einsatz.
Ach, AngularJS.
Boah, das ist ja dann uralt schon.
Oder wenn Komponenten stark verändert werden.
Werden dann durch React-Komponenten ausgesetzt, ausgetauscht.
Das fängt im Prinzip schon ganz am Anfang an, wenn man die Probleme von dem Benutzer erzählt bekommt, dann die erst mal greifen muss, die evaluiert, aufbereitet, in eine Lösungsfindung reingeht, das am Ende dann auch umsetzt.
Ich glaube, dass sie das wirklich sehr cool finden.
Aber es hätte nicht geschadet, das etwas enthusiastischer im Video rüberzubringen.
Beobachten kann, wie das dann beim Benutzer ankommt.
Ich finde, wir sind da auch vollständig integriert.
Es ist nicht, dass wir einfach nur etwas vorgesetzt bekommen und das umsetzen sollen, sondern wir können unsere eigenen Gedanken halt mit einbringen.
Und das gibt auch mehr so ein Gefühl von Selbstverwirklichung, die damit einhergeht.
Okay, das ist doch eher so ein bisschen Startup mit Vision und wir brennen für die Sache und sowas.
Ich finde das sehr beeindruckend.
Es ist sehr befriedigend, wenn man spürt, dass man einfach mit seiner Arbeit einen Impact hat und dass es unsere Kunden weiterbringt bei ihrem Business.
Wenn ein Arbeitgeber sowas mit dir macht, will ich sehen, wie begeistert du bist, wenn er was macht.
Einmal im Monat den Open Code Friday, wo wir uns spannenden Experimenten widmen können, haben wir zum Beispiel letztlich in unserem Team eine Rust-Application entwickelt.
Was sonst? Was sonst?
Okay, das muss ein Startup sein.
Blazingly Fast war die hoffentlich auch.
Und wir haben auch so ein Format wie die Brown Bag Session am Mittwoch.
Die ist dafür da, damit Leute coole Themen, die sie sich angeschaut haben, einfach den anderen Leuten beibringen können und halt so einen coolen Wissensaustausch.
Bei uns nennt sich das, wie heißt das bei uns, wir haben auch sowas, aber wir haben keine Brown Bag Session.
Bei uns ist das ganz normale Arbeitszeit und es wird auch nicht gegessen dabei.
Das heißt bei uns.
Tech Talk heißt das bei uns.
Gestalten können.
Und wir haben klassisch dann auch noch die Bücherflat.
Eigentlich ganz cool, wenn man so altmodisch, sage ich mal, sich noch die Lektüre ins Bett legen möchte.
Kann sie auch im Tablet lesen.
Im Tablet lesen.
Grundsätzlich haben wir das so organisiert, dass die Teams sich da einfach individuell organisieren.
Das heißt, es muss für das Team passen und alles kann, nichts muss.
Ich arbeite selbst primär.
Können auch Linux-Desktops?
Also nicht hier aus Offenburg.
Und ich muss sagen, es funktioniert super.
Also ich fühle mich auch komplett eingegliedert bei uns im Team.
Und man merkt am Ende des Tages fast gar
nicht, dass man eigentlich bei sich zu Hause im Büro ist und nicht hier in Offenburg.
Habe jetzt frisch Nachwuchs bekommen und
diese Flexibilität hilft mir natürlich schon zu Hause auch meine Frau zu unterstützen.
Das ist sehr nice.
Homeoffice ist eh das Beste, gerade in solchen Berufen.
Da macht es meistens überhaupt keinen Sinn, ob du vor Ort bist oder remote, egal.
Ja, man für manche Sachen lasse ich mir das durchaus gefallen.
Aber das meiste ist egal.
GG.
Ja, ja, ja, so Krachmann.
Ja, ja, hier ist.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist gar nicht übel.
Also wenn, wenn, wenn man hier so Bock da drauf hat, haben wir noch was anderes.
Data Development Marketing.
Wer macht eigentlich bei denen die Infrastruktur?
Ich sehe Development.
Wer macht denn jetzt eigentlich mein?
Und selbst wenn die keine eigene haben, wovon ich ausgehe, dass sie kein eigenes
Rechenzentrum haben, in dem klassischen Sinn.
Irgendeiner muss sich ja schon um die Sache kümmern.
Wir haben sicherlich die ein oder anderen Linux VMs.
Ihre Anwendung muss irgendwo drauf laufen.
Ah, da gibt's auch Cloud.
Ja, dann ergibt das ergibt das sicherlich Sinn.
Senior Cloud Engineer.
Ach, gucke mal.
Das wäre was für mich.
Ich bin mit fast 40.
Wobei ich ja aktuell Senior Linux Engineer bin, aber ich mache hauptsächlich Cloud.
Letztendlich sind die Namen eh Schall und Rauch.
Moin.
Ja.
Eins kopieren.
Okay, also Your Mission Senior Cloud Engineer.
Dynamic Platform Team Designing Implementing Managing Cloud Infrastructure Deep Expertise.
Muss es AWS sein?
Die einzige Cloud Plattform, von der ich.
Keine Ahnung, ich will mich eh nicht bewerben.
Ich sag's euch. Die einzige Cloud Plattform, von der ich nicht großartig Ahnung habe.
Von den Großen.
Strong Understanding of Kubernetes.
Ja, das habe ich, aber nicht auf AWS.
Und bei AWS heißt der Campbell auch immer anders.
Die Benahmung bei AWS ist so pepega jedes Mal.
Also du kannst eigentlich, wenn du.
Okay.
Mal ein Beispiel.
Also wenn ihr irgendeinen Artikel lest über
irgendwelche Cloud Geschichten und da kommen permanent Begriffe drin vor,
die keinen Sinn ergeben, dann ist die Chance sehr hoch, dass es um AWS geht.
Weil bei AWS heißen alle Services irgendwie random.
Du weißt nicht, was es sein soll.
Ich finde, das ist bei Google eigentlich ganz gut gelöst.
Das meiste hat bei Google irgendwie einen halbwegs griffigen Namen.
Welche Cloud Anbieter bevorzugt zu Azure, Google oder Google oder Amazon?
IBM Cloud.
Nein, Leute, ich bevorzuge natürlich SAP Cloud.
Logischerweise.
Was sonst?
Pepo Burn Money.
Wobei SAP Cloud auch nur aufsetzt auf.
Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Ich habe es euch letztens erzählt im Stream.
Die haben gar keine eigene Cloud.
Magenta Cloud ja vor allem.
Also
ich muss mittlerweile sagen.
Früher hätte ich gesagt Azure.
Mittlerweile muss ich sagen, Google hat schon ein paar ganz coole Sachen.
Und ich habe den Eindruck, wobei mir der aktuelle Vergleich zu Azure fehlt, weil
privat kannst du da nicht viel ausprobieren.
Mir fehlt der Up to Date Vergleich zu Azure.
Aber ich habe den Eindruck, bei Google
bewegen sich die Sachen ein bisschen schneller als in Azure.
Also nicht insgesamt schneller.
Microsoft frickelt auch den ganzen Tag drumherum.
Aber bei Google entwickeln sich die
sinnvollen Sachen schneller in sinnvolle Richtungen wie bei Microsoft.
Zum Beispiel
als Google jetzt relativ schnell geschafft, wo eventuell
sogar ich mit dran beteiligt war, dass das schneller, schneller geht,
weil wir genug gemeckert haben.
Sie haben es endlich geschafft, jetzt das einfacher und zu verbessern, dass du
schnelleren und vor allem mehr lokalen Storage bekommst an deine Cloud.
Vor allem oder nicht.
Nicht unbedingt vor allem sein.
Aber unter der Haube sind vor allem auch
deine Komponente des Klasters oder der Haube ganz normale vor allem bei Google,
dass du lokal etatschte SSD dran bekommst.
Das geht schon lange.
Das ging schon immer meiner Meinung nach bei Google besser als bei Azure.
Zumindest meine bisschen outdated der Erfahrung nach.
Aber mittlerweile kannst du sogar noch mehr
als 12 Terabyte dranhängen und das auch besser handeln.
Und eventuell habe ich sogar mitgeholfen indirekt, dass das so ist,
weil wir sind den so auf den Sack gegangen deswegen, weil das so richtig schrottig war.
Und haben die genervt.
Und wisst ihr, was Google dann gesagt hat?
Die haben den, die haben den besten Spruch aller Zeiten gebracht.
Den habt ihr auch schon tausendmal benutzt.
Also stellt euch vor, wir haben Rücksprache mit Google.
Da sitzen Google Leute und du erzählst, dass du Probleme hast und gerade local
Storage etatscht und du würdest dir wünschen, dass du lokalen Storage vor allem
mehr etatschen kannst und nicht in so kleinen Häppchen.
Und dann sagen sie Aha, verstehe, verstehe, Problem erkannt.
Ja, verstehen wir.
Und dann was sagt man, wenn man es nicht wirklich besser weiß?
Und wenn man es nicht gleich machen kann?
Was ist? Was ist die ultimative Antwort?
Habt ihr auch schon tausendmal benutzt?
Das nehmen wir mit.
Richtig, wir nehmen es mit.
Und in dem Fall muss man sagen.
Google hat es nicht nur mitgenommen, Google hat auch was dran gemacht.
Natürlich kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, ob das jetzt Google nur gemacht hat, weil wir
öfters genug gemeckert haben oder weil wir plus sehr viele andere darüber
gemeckert haben, wie schlecht das gewesen ist.
Also.
Wahrscheinlich waren wir nicht die Einzigen, die das gerne hätten.
Leider hat es Google zumindest jetzt in der Zwischenzeit noch.
Ich glaube, das wird auch ein bisschen gelockert demnächst.
Noch mit super krassen Hardwarekosten verbunden oder mit super krassen Kosten
für die für die VMs ist ja nicht wirklich Hardware für die VMs verbunden, denn du
kannst diese neue Local besonders großen Local Attached SSDs nur mit einer ganz
speziellen, mit einem ganz speziellen Maschinetype verwenden oder speziellen
Maschinetypes verwenden und die sind ultra teuer.
Da bezahlst du.
Also unter vierstellig im Monat geht schon mal gar nix.
Wenn du da eine richtig fette Kiste brauchst,
mit allen Drohnen dran ist, kostet die einzelne VM ist eher fünfstellig.
Aktuell die einzelne.
Ich betone das noch mal die einzelne VM plus inklusiv, also inklusive VM inklusive
Storage fünfstellig im Monat eine VM eine fünfstellig.
Also das ist doch nicht so wirklich praktikabel, was wir da gebaut haben, aber
ich bin froh, dass sie das Problem erkannt haben und was dran machen.
Okay, also sie wollen Kubernetes.
Stelz Cloud Architect Design Deployer.
Kubernetes Orchestration Terraform.
Ja, ja, das ist im Prinzip genau das, was ich mir vorstelle.
So unter dem Cloud Engineer, was die haben wollen.
Monitoring Logging. Ja.
Prometheus, Grafana, Cloudwatch, New Relic.
Gut, Metric, Metric, Stelz.
Wobei New Relic ist nicht für Metric, New Relic ist für
Metris und sowas. Ja, im Prinzip genau das, was ich mir darunter vorstellen würde.
Ja, gut, da hätte ich verkackt.
AWS habe ich keine sieben Jahre Erfahrung.
Ich habe sieben Jahre Erfahrung in dem Gebiet.
Ja, ich habe mehr Erfahrung in dem Gebiet, aber
ich meine, ich habe Erfahrung im DevOps Bereich.
Noch bevor das überhaupt so hieß.
Leider halt nix mit AWS.
Aber wie gesagt, ich sage nochmal, ich suche hier gar nicht für mich.
Ich bin happy da, wo ich bin zurzeit.
Alles gut.
Networking, Kubernetes, MySQL, NoSQL,
Vents, Proficiency, Infrastructure as Code, Automation, Terraform, GitLab CI,
GitHub Actions. Ja, passt alles.
Java, Kotlin. Ja,
siehste, das ist tatsächlich
ein Technologie Stack, da habe ich keine Ahnung von.
Noch am ehesten Node.js von der ganzen Sache.
Product Mindset, proaktiv, analytical approach.
Ja, okay, jetzt wissen wir zumindest auch, wer bei denen die Infrastruktur betreibt.
Nämlich den, den sie gerade suchen.
Okay, ich sehe, wir haben so viele Sachen noch offen.
Wir müssen morgen nochmal.
Wir müssen morgen nochmal streamen.
22.07.
Ich muss jetzt.
Ja, damit fangen wir morgen an.
Weil die Stellenanzeige wurde mir schon angekündigt.
Die ist wirklich richtig schlecht.
Konnte man nicht irgendwie alle Book machen?
Speichern nur für den Fall der Fälle, dass ich das irgendwie
zu machen, morgen nicht mehr aufkriege.
Du musst Windows Updates machen.
Dann bist du morgen ca.
Weiß ich noch nicht. Nach der Arbeit irgendwann.
Also wieder, wieder wahrscheinlich 19 Uhr oder so oder Bett geteilt.
Leute, schön, dass ihr dabei wart.
Wenn es euch gefallen hat, lasst ein Follow da.
Muss ja nicht gleich ein Sub sein.
Freue ich mich. Grüne Pfeile nach oben zeigen Big Stonks.
Bettke.
Kann das sein?
Wir hatten doch mal so ein unanständiges Bett geemote.
Das gibt es nicht mehr, oder?
Ich glaube, das wurde gelöscht.
Doch haben wir noch.
Haben wir noch.
Oder ist es ein privates von dir?
Nee, ich kann jetzt zumindest nicht gleich pennen.
Ich muss jetzt noch mal eine Runde Kopio machen und noch eine Runde Salz.
Salzlösung inhalieren, weil ich so einen trockenen Hals habe.
So ich das ganze Geschwätze.
Und dann gehe ich pennen.
Also bis dann.
Leute, wir sehen uns morgen.
Macht's gut.
Das ist ein gutes Emote.
Wir hatten das Emote gemacht.
Das finde ich richtig cool.
Ugu Bia Bia.
Gibst du wieder?
Nicht so schlimm wie das letzte Mal.
Es war ja Massive Hustke angesagt.
So, ich habe den Vorschau Rechner schon aus, Leute.
Bis morgen. Macht's gut.
Ziu.